we're going to start this news out with
some breaking news Al jazeera's land
Russia will extend a U.N brokered grain
deal guaranteeing safe supplies from
Ukrainian ports according to senior
Turkish officials the deal which was set
to expire on Wednesday will continue for
now the agreements allowed millions of
tons of Ukrainian grain to be shipped
through Black Sea ports blockaded by
Russia we're going to go straight to our
correspondent synonym Castillo who's
live for us in Istanbul that was a
threat by Russia that it might not
extend this deal now we're hearing it
probably will go ahead
well we are hearing from the Turkish
authorities that the meeting is still
underway but it is on most of the topics
the the parties have agreed however we
heard Kremlin spokesperson Pasco saying
that before until we hear from a
statement official statement from Russia
uh we should wait so apparently the
meeting that was held on May 10 among
the deputy defense ministers it has come
to a specific uh point because back then
the Russian officials have stated their
concerns about uh the deal the the deal
was brokered by the U.S and U.N and
turkey in Istanbul and it's actually
allowed both Ukrainian and Russian
Brands and fertilizers to reach Global
markets however Russia claims that still
that commitment hasn't been in place it
just it just only focuses on Ukrainian
there that's why Russia has been
slow in renewing the last extension this
is the situation but we know that
Turkish president
was expected to speak with Russian
counterpart Vladimir Putin so if there
is we we will probably hear the
extension of the deal from the
presidents of both sides Rob yeah we're
talking about the fact that this deal
was negotiated by the U.N and turkey and
we have seen in the past when grain has
been there's been a threat to grain
supplies from Ukraine that has pushed
prices up around the world if this deal
hadn't been extended do we have any
indication of what the impact might have
been
of course I mean we know that there is a
food crisis around the globe especially
among the poor countries drop and when
the the parties signed the steel last
year in June June 2022. the priority was
to focus on poor countries especially in
Africa to bring grains to them as they
are in need the most however during the
previous meetings especially a joint
during a joint press conference between
Turkish and Russian foreign ministers a
few weeks ago in the Turkish capital
Ankara Russian foreign minister Laro
said that the Ukrainian grains were not
going to the poor countries but actually
to Europe who do not imminently need
those grains but the deal was signed in
a different framework and when there is
a when the extension time came back in
March 18 Russia has approved it just one
one day before the expiration date so we
see that Russia is pushing pushing its
borders because they believe their
national interests are not being
recognized despite another deal was
signed to free Russia's fertilizers and
Grains to the global markets but of
course if this deal is not extended this
is a this is a problem not only about
food crisis but also about food prices
and the hunger in poor countries because
so far 30 million tons of grains have
crossed Bosphorus coming from North this
way crossing the bus first reaching out
to Dardanelles and then reaching to a
Mediterranean and agencies and other
Global markets so if this journey a
naval Journey doesn't continue then it
is a problem not only for poor countries
but also in developing countries who are
dealing with high inflation so now all
eyes are on the possible phone talk
between Turkish and Russian presidents
hoping that the deal is extended
in istanbulum thank you very much indeed
well the Dealer's extension is going to
come as a relief to Ukraine's farmers
and countries which rely on its grain
exports Natasha Batha reports from
zwanzitsky in Western Ukraine
spring in Western Ukraine this young
wheat will be ready to harvest in two
months but Farmers here worry they won't
be able to sell it because the war has
severely disrupted exports
Alina's family has owned this farm for
decades she says Russia's blockade of
Black Sea ports a new import
restrictions in some EU countries are
hampering trade
since the port blockades we've not been
able to send by sea so we started
exporting via our western border to
Poland and Hungary but now they've
banned our grains so our trucks have to
carry our products all the way to Italy
Poland Hungary and three other countries
recently banned Imports of Ukrainian
grain to prevent a glut although the
grain can still Transit through them
it's forced this Farm to find new
clients further afield but Logistics are
pushing up costs and not being able to
export easily means millions of dollars
worth of grain could be lost
usually at this time of year all of the
Grain on this farm would have been sold
but because of the war and all the
problems linked to it half of last
year's Harvest is still here having to
be stocked in the silos and in these
huge plastic sleeves
a few kilometers from Poland's border
this rail Transport company is trying to
get things moving we have here European
wagons which are already loaded with the
Ukrainian grain and it's ready for
transit to the Polish Port of Dansk the
manager says the wars changed everything
they didn't transport grain before The
Invasion now it accounts for 50 of the
business we had a lot of requests to
support Ukrainian Farmers for export
wear grains into Europe and from that
moment we started to construct a new
Grain Terminal
as one of the world's main grain
producers Ukraine's exports are
essential for its economy and to feed
people around the world
Valeri says transporting it at such a
vital time isn't just about supporting
the war effort it's also a way to build
more connections with the European Union
the Kiev is on track to join one day
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera sofkievski
Western Ukraine